now to china where a cleanup operation
is underway in the country's central
hennan province after
devastating floods days of heavy rain
has left much of the region submerged at
least 33 people have been killed
thousands displaced and
many are still missing but there was a
moment of hope when rescuers pulled
a three-month-old baby from a collapsed
building in
shenzhou city local media say the baby
had been buried under the rubble for a
day and a night before being found
the child is now in hospital as and is
in a stable condition
many areas in henan province still lack
basic
services and residents are taking stock
of the devastation
flood waters rushed through ganges city
near the capital of henan province
leaving behind not only an immense
cleanup but also an immeasurable sense
of loss
i really don't know what to say i lost
my shop
i lost my house i lost everything
things won't be returning to normal
anytime soon with authorities struggling
to cope with the scale of the disaster
we don't have water to drink now and we
don't have electricity
the cell phone signal only resumed today
days of heavy rain have brought cities
in henan province to a standstill
stranded residents wait for rescue boats
or heavy machinery to carry them to
safety
even now the scale of the disaster is
still emerging
subway commuters watched the waters fill
up the carriages
all the way up to their necks
many died in this incident on wednesday
before emergency workers could reach
those trapped inside
horrific images like these creating
widespread anger
authorities didn't shut down trains
earlier
still dozens of reservoirs and dams are
in danger of overflowing
and the government says it has deployed
soldiers to divert rivers
which burst their banks
our teams have rushed to zhengzhou yang
kaifung and other places in the region
other troops in hanan province are ready
to participate
more than 3 million people in hanan
province have been affected by the
record rains
with tens of thousands now living in
emergency shelters
others have been out on the streets
picking through the mud
to see what remains
well correspondent matthias berlinga is
in shangzhou the capital of hanon
province which has been
hit hardest by the flooding mathias
what's the situation there today
so i am now a little bit outside of the
city one of the areas that
was hit first and hardest and i don't
know how well you can see but behind me
this river was overflowing the bridges
that were crossing this river are
destroyed
i am on a road bridge that has survived
that
was more solid and this is the only
place in this whole area where we have
mobile reception
all the other places are still cut off
from the world roads are blocked it's
very hard to access these places
and people are looking at the damage
houses have been damaged people
are telling stories about people about
people that have been
carried away by the floods they still
when they were standing on the street
they still do not have
any information about what happened to
them
it's pretty much a mess here although
the rain has stopped and although as you
can see the water levels
are down now but there is a lot to do
here and there's a lot of things that
will come out after the the there is
more access to the area
now rescue operations are ongoing across
henan province how many people
are in need of help there matthias
it's very hard to say as i told you
there are some places around here that
are not accessible
at all others are accessible but only by
foot because the roads have been
have been swept away so um it's a very
it's it's very hard and
the authorities are not really very open
they're not really disclosing
uh information in a timely manner
um it seems that they are under big
pressure yesterday evening for example
we were in one of the places a tunnel in
in in junzhou city where a lot of people
had
died at that moment or many people were
suspected to die because
many cars were trapped inside the tunnel
um authorities have said two people have
died but
uh this is not very probable that it
will stay at that
death toll the mayor of zhongzhou came
there at midnight
in with the policeman without press and
police were pushing us away she was
having a look at the scene but she did
not
want it to be seen at this place you did
not want to be associated
with what was happening there now i
understand that dams
and rivers are still at risk of
overflowing
their matias are forecasters expecting
more rain
well the situation now i am a little bit
west of jungle and here the rains have
stopped but north of zhengzhou they're
still continuing
and there are still uh uh roads being
flooded
and rivers rising um
we do expect indeed more rain i
am not sure how heavy it will be i think
but it could be quite severe again in
the next two days
this is not over and you can see the
weather it's not bright or anything this
is not gone it's just that the rain
has moved from one place to the other
we're also hearing matthias that the
floods are affecting supply chains
what can you tell us about that
is one of the it is in the central
chinese plane it's a very
important transport hub a lot of lines
run through hernan it is
also one place that the government has
tried to develop as an industrial base
as the coastal regions the traditional
industries
yeah we've got some technical problems
with our line there too china at the
moment that was matthias berlinga
reporting live from zhengzhou in the
center of china's
flood zone